hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
go what's going on everybody how are you
you're making it through another week
you're you're joe
six-pack you're putting your [ __ ]
panties on one laced leg at a time
um why would you have legs on your
panties well maybe
you were raised right and you're not
like all these who is
on the social media with half their
[ __ ] clams hanging out of the back of
their yoga pants
it's her body if she's proud of her
vagina
it wants to make it look like a sock
puppet inside of her sweatpants
that's her business you know upon
further review i've looked back at my
comments about women's vaginas that i've
never met
and i'm disgusted with myself and i'd
like to apologize and say that i am now
an ally
of having your vagina lip showing
through
your yoga pants see that people
you see how that works that is the power
of all of these
social justice warriors i just had made
the ignorant statement
i canceled myself i then apologized and
became an ally
all by myself
uh don't know much about this [ __ ]
but i do know i don't give a [ __ ] um oh
my god
maybe i'm talking about the vag lips
there um
not because of why you think not because
i'm a bald
ignorant sex tossy like
karen eater of dolphin meat
um
dude i saw a [ __ ] up video i don't
know all these boats were driving these
[ __ ] dolphins or something
porpoises or orcas or something into the
[ __ ]
the cove there oh they made a movie
about it
and uh these [ __ ] guys were in the
goddamn water
just like putting them in headlocks and
stabbing them in the [ __ ] head it's
just like i was surprised that the
dolphins didn't try to
bite their legs you know i know they
don't have shark teeth
they kind of like baby shark teeth baby
shark teeth
right you can still do some damage rip
off an achilles
i don't know what a [ __ ] job
[ __ ] just sitting in there a sea of
blood
coming home hi honey how was work
it was great uh
what'd you make for dinner i made some
trout
where are you going
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know i'm not saying don't love my
wife that's when you know when a guy's
going to say something [ __ ] up about
his wife you know
it's not like i don't love my wife but
you know it's like i'm out there in a
[ __ ]
cove committing dolphin genocide
and and i come home fish for dinner
it's like lady how about a burger in a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um only in march it used to be steak in
a blow job but now with the the
the new normal it's now burger and a
handy
burger no cheese no cheese on that
burger lettuce
wrapped um oh man the [ __ ] boston
bruins got
their asses
last night uh down in tampa
no it was in boston i'm just gonna buy
their jerseys i'm pretending that
they're playing
home and away games um yeah we just got
we got smoked
uh what we were worried about happened
last night um
with tuka rask leaving people big
question mark
on halaq who my friend informed me was
like something like the 271st
draft pick in 2003 but he's still in the
league
so that says to me we maybe got a little
tom brady action going on here right
uh he had a tough game last night i
still believe in the guy he's played
he's played great
for us um you know a couple of soft
goals here or there but i mean it
happens he has a bad game
you know what you know what you do you
know what you do
you shake it off bruins are gonna shake
it off we're gonna tie it up in the next
one and i'm sure the entire
boston sports media is now saying this
[ __ ] series is over
which it may be
because i think you know once we put in
the other guy
after luck i mean i don't know who else
we go for after that i guess she put in
the guy who's driving the [ __ ]
zamboni
hoping he's wearing some long underwear
so his thighs don't get bruised
um his shins actually um
i love when the sports meter just they
just fold the [ __ ] tent and i always
wanted an athlete
you know after a bad loss you know we've
lost two in a row we were up one out
now we're down uh two to one and then
they just start being these
negative nellies and i always wanted an
athlete to look across the [ __ ] table
or maybe just across that stupid [ __ ]
recorder that they have
you know because they're not smart
enough to remember anything that they
heard not because they want to get it
word for word i love that they actually
record it and then they still take
things out of context
it's like how can you [ __ ] this up um
i always wanted the athlete to be like
do you know what the difference between
me and you is other than
an astounding athletic ability all right
there man tits
is that when
we lose a couple games in a row
you know we still go positive we're
gonna turn this thing around
we're gonna make our adjustments and
we're gonna go down swinging as opposed
to you [ __ ] guys
you sports writers who just fold the
[ __ ] tent
the second you see a cloud in the sky
you know
and what do they do right do when you
lose a game do you start you know do the
bruins go in there and point to their
goaltender
no they rally around the guy what do the
sports writers do they try and take
the guy out you know and that's why
the only [ __ ] ring a sports writer's
ever gonna get is a wedding ring
telling him he better have his [ __ ]
article done by 11 o'clock cause he's
got dishes to do
i hate how negative that just they just
they're just quitters
they're all [ __ ] quitters
i'm trying to think the last time i read
a sports article
that when your team wins the first game
loses the next two
dozen starts forecasting gloom and doom
and i'll tell you you know it's not just
the sports writers it's also sports fans
they do it too and i'm telling you
there's a disease
that that's a little seed you know
the first time you played hopscotch when
you were a little kid and you're on one
leg and you bend down to pick up the
rock and you did a face plant you got a
little [ __ ] raspberry on your
forehead
that's right there where it started to
take growth right and you started
thinking uh you know there's something
wrong with me
uh you avoided hopscotch after that then
you start [ __ ] forgetting your gym
class stuff so you don't have to
participate
you know and then walking out instead of
walking up to an eight in a bar
you're talking to some four right it's a
[ __ ] disease
and in the back of your head there's
that voice of who you should have been
rather than who you became and the only
way you can drown out
drown it out is to trash the local
hockey team that's now down two to one
that's my theory
all right now you're listening to
somebody who's
overcome a lot of adversity when i was a
child okay i was born a white male
but i was beyond white i was a white
that was not
accepted i had orange dots all over my
body
my hair was the color of a creamsicle um
sorry i still believe in the bruins i i
think that uh
we just have too much hot and i think
we're going to rally around halak i
think hello has a great game
the next game we tie it up 2-2 and i
think none of the sports writers
apologize for doubting him
i'm sure they're throwing tuka under the
[ __ ] bus because he chose his family
over whatever the [ __ ] it is that we're
watching hockey in august with no fans
you know if you told people last year
hey this season's gonna end
uh in august okay
and none of the regular season is gonna
count we're gonna do a round robin
and i don't give a [ __ ] if you had close
to 100 points you could actually be
[ __ ] a goddamn 8th seat
in three games or whatever the [ __ ] it
is that they did
and there's going to be no fans they
would have been like what the [ __ ]
you know but uh the great thing about
sports is once you just start watching
you don't give a [ __ ] because i don't
give a [ __ ] and i and i am counting this
[ __ ]
this stanley cup whoever wins this is a
legit stanley cup and
because uh everybody's in the same boat
you know it's not like um
i don't know they all have to
participate
so it's not like one team didn't have to
and the other teams did
so i don't have a problem with it i do
have a problem with us giving up [ __ ]
seven goals though and i think
uh i'm gonna go out on a limb and think
the bruins do too and you know what
the bottom line is tampa bay
um you know maybe they're going to get a
little too confident i don't [ __ ]
know i'm just hoping they can win
anyways your philadelphia flyers
your number one seed speaking of
creamsicles the philadelphia flyers
after getting their [ __ ] orange and
white [ __ ] butts
spanked in the first game what did they
do
they came right back gave the islanders
the old right there fred i believe they
won that one in overtime i've not seen a
second of that series game three is
tonight
and uh i cannot wait to watch it uh i'm
very excited to see these this seems
like it's a an incredible matchup
and i'm psyched that it's one one
because uh i got nothing else to do i
want to see this thing go seven games
bruins on the other hand i want them to
[ __ ] win the next three games in a
row
but the flyers and islanders can just
beat the [ __ ] out of each other for
seven games for i like you
um that's what i think um so
but thank god for sports thank god for
sports coming back
because you can actually you know well i
say you can get away from
the problems of the world and then now
the milwaukee bucks aren't going to play
because of uh everything that happened
that horrific stuff that happened in
wisconsin and then the response in
kenosha and uh
jesus christ it's just oh you know i
i just don't understand you know and
says somebody i can you really have to
i will say just stay off social media
because the [ __ ]
level of racists that are on there i saw
this one guy this is actually he's so
racist
like he doesn't even realize he's racist
so he's trying to uh justify why you
would shoot a guy
seven times in the back you know as he's
getting into his car and his kids are in
there
and his response is he shows a video of
a black guy
fighting with cops
it's like um maybe because of this
and he was literally defining racism
so like now because this black guy did
this that means they're all going to do
it so just shoot him
right i mean that would that is the that
is the same
[ __ ] like that would be like if i
showed a picture of charles manson
you know and be like you know that's
then not now the cops can shoot every
white guy in the back
seven [ __ ] times um
yeah i just feel like there's just
certain people that are just choosing
not to see that there's a problem and um
you got to just kind of work around
because i don't know [ __ ] about society
or any of that crap but i will say
that [ __ ] 17 year old kid who just
murdered those people
with an assault rifle the fact that he
can walk down the street afterwards
towards the cops wearing an assault
rifle with his
hands up okay
and they're like hey get out of the road
step aside please
i mean who would you rather be in that
situation a white guy walking down the
street with an assault rifle with the
arms up
or a black guy walking down the street
with his arms up wearing a book bag
i'm telling you and you know if you
think that that's
for some liberal horseshit then uh agree
to disagree
i mean there's definitely you know
i think uh one of the great people that
i've seen in sports is doc rivers and if
you
listen to what he said about it
and the emotion that he had for it i
mean for you to still sit there
as someone who isn't him and living his
experience and tell him that what he's
saying is wrong
is uh i mean that's a level of [ __ ]
ego that i do not want to be around so
there you go
that's it that's what i have to say on
that shits but um
as ugly as all of this is i think it's
finally come to a head
and um i do think that we're gonna be
in a much better place after this
um i don't think that those people that
write that racist [ __ ]
and that people that take assault rifles
and just shoot unarmed innocent [ __ ]
people
um and i know right a little interceptor
out there [ __ ] ready
it's just like that doesn't mean you can
just go out and shoot them
you know if you start rioting yeah you
should be arrested and then you should
be but you shouldn't just get shot
by some random [ __ ] person
shot dead like i don't think that you
should get the death penalty for that
because some citizen who's not even in
law enforcement
who's actually a kid decides um
whatever i don't know it's brutal let's
just let's you know
let's pick a lighter subject and talk
about how much weight i put on
um out there in yellow springs oh my god
i got ice cream twice one milkshake i'm
trying to think of the damage i did i
got a head of roast beef sandwich with
chips and an orange soda
i had like two root beers i tried
ratatouille
this is how much of a patent oswald fan
i am i went into a restaurant i've never
seen it on the menu
and i just saw ratatouille it was like
oh my god
patton oswalt was the voice in
ratatouille i will have the ratatouille
and just like the movie i enjoyed it um
a tremendous dish i still can't tell you
what it was it was it was some sort of
um
some sort of minced meat i don't know
what it was uh it was delicious i don't
give a [ __ ] it was a rat
you know it was delicious you know you
boil those [ __ ] take the hair off
them
tastes like chicken no it doesn't
no it doesn't i had alligator one time
and it did not taste like chicken it
tasted like weird chicken
um that's the best i'll give it okay
that's like all these [ __ ] cars that
you know try to act like they're a
porsche or a [ __ ] bmw it's like
you're not
okay you're a volkswagen and you
are a chevy cavalier um no i'm sorry
you're a toyota camry you're not a bmw 5
series well i got to tell you you know
you got the twin turbo
boop your
who knows yeah so i think i had already
put on five pounds and then i put on
like another six pounds
and uh so
i was going i started going to this
juice place and uh
they had these cool t-shirts and i saw i
bought one
and they're like what size do you want
and i got the medium i didn't get the
large
because i know the medium i have to be
in tip-top
shape to uh
to rock as the kids say a medium t-shirt
all right now i could have made the
mistake of buying the large t-shirt
and just walk down the street and every
three steps pull the shirt away from my
belly you know you do that when you
start getting fat
you start pulling the [ __ ] you know
the clingy shirt because it's showing
your [ __ ]
jlo curves your reverse j-lo curves
you got a j-lo ass where your stomach's
supposed to be
um i got the medium
and oh my god i put that thing on what a
[ __ ] show
my man tits were coming out the side my
[ __ ] arms were all i just i looked
[ __ ] like i was full of sugar and
salt and soda all of that
i just was carbonated [ __ ] i just was uh
i looked terrible
um so since i've come back
i've gone back onto my diet and um i was
just like all right well i know how this
works
i just did uh seven days of damage
which means i'll have to do anywhere
from 14 to 20 days
of being a saint and that's
that's the sad math of trying to stay in
shape because you can get on an
elliptical
and do an hour come off pouring sweat
and within depending on how fast you eat
you could eat a sleeve of oreo cookies
under 10 minutes and i don't know i
don't
i don't know how long you have to be on
an elliptical to burn that off
because there is nothing in there
that you need and it's just gonna go
right to your man tits right to your
[ __ ]
back fat it's gonna be hanging off the
underside of your jaw
so anyway that's what that's what i've
been doing because um i need to get back
in shape because i'm vain
and number two i have some social
distance
shows coming up all right
um everybody is learning from what dave
is doing out there in ohio
and uh bert kreischer and all these guys
and they're getting it down and they got
it down
to like a science so i'm going to be
doing some shows
that i will be announcing um very soon
probably before my next podcast
and uh i am very excited to go do it
it's going to be like the old days
where i'm going to be doing two shows a
night in front of like 300 people
um and i'll have to do like 9 000 shows
in the week so i can keep the lights on
but my act is going to be tight as a
[ __ ] so i'm looking
i'm really looking forward to it and um
yeah um and i'm going to go off
because i want the freedom that i had
that i used to have as a comedian where
i could just say whatever the [ __ ] i
wanted to say
i really want to get back to that um
and i don't know i'm telling jokes
i mean what's the worst case scenario
they end my acting career that doesn't
really exist
[Laughter]
boohoo then i just do a podcast and do
stand-up i mean that's kind of a great
existence
and uh considering all the amazing
dad time i've had with my kids like uh
that wouldn't bother me um
to just do that i mean obviously i
wouldn't want to
be uh have a bunch of [ __ ] hairy leg
[ __ ] chicks
[ __ ] get mad at me although it would
be fun to talk about their hairy legs
even if they didn't have them
and just be like oh i thought i just i
you know you were painting with the
broad brush
no pun intended i figured i could do it
too can i
no it's difficult you do it but when
we're sexist
it's brave um anyway let me do a little
uh a little
advertising read here um
candid candid you know there hasn't been
a whole lot to smile about these last
few months
going negative come on man
how about all the [ __ ] home-cooked
meals
everybody now right now is like smiling
through like gritted teeth
yeah it's so gorgeous in my family every
day
uh but things are getting better there
you go candid there you go
speaking of which wait a minute i gotta
pause on this read did you guys read you
got to read jerry
seinfeld's article that he wrote in the
new york times some comedy club owner
said new york is dead and i'm leaving
and that [ __ ] article that jerry
seinfeld
wrote i'm telling you is everything that
is missing in the democratic and the
republican party
right now all right it was
positive it was confident it had swagger
he was talking [ __ ] this is new york
we've been through way worse than this
and if you're too much of a [ __ ] to
[ __ ] it i might
put words in his box but basically
that's what i why i've needed since the
beginning of this
all right i needed my fellow my the
first ginger president and look what he
does
i needed him to get on there
and just be like this is the greatest
country this is america we will defeat
this the way we defeated the germans of
the japanese
the way we said we defeated the north
vietnamese i needed that
that's what i needed all right we're
gonna find a cure
[ __ ] relax everybody wear a goddamn
mask stay away from each other
we will defeat this and we will continue
on as the greatest nation on earth earth
earth earth yes that's what i needed and
it's just been a bunch of oh well they
started in you came from here and these
people won't let me do this
on both sides of the aisle everybody
just wetting their pants
um that's what i want come november i
don't give a [ __ ] who wins i want a
leader
i want somebody that's gonna come back
in the locker room
and have us all running out for the next
[ __ ] goddamn half
ready to [ __ ] you know light somebody
up that's what i want
oh i'm not gonna get it oh we got two
ballest
[ __ ] octogenarians
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh boy jesus christ
i got an idea why don't we stop vetting
people so people with balls can run for
office again because i swear to god now
you just got these
[ __ ] mamby pamby i don't know i don't
know what happened
jesus christ um anyways candid everybody
you know there hasn't been a whole lot
to smile about these last few months but
things are getting better
please talk about things you see
improving i see my man tits coming down
since i came back from the road
um i
see uh you know i see a nice clean house
oh it's getting tougher i uh what else
do i see improving
um uh i got the new iphone
and it's better than my last one for
example being able to physically
be around friends family sporting events
outside sporting events starting back up
thank you candid sporting events
starting back up uh
doing stand-up out in a cornfield i got
some stand up dates coming the sun's
coming over the horizon
there we go got back to flying
helicopters
you know there's a good thing woke up
this morning i took a shower
you know felt good did a little bit of
stretching
who is it hey
i'm in the middle of an ad read those
are things you can't help but smile
about right
um do you have a mega smile megawatt
smile to show off do you nia
no yeah well my friends over at camden
candid can help
can it can cl candid clear aligners are
comfortable removable
and totally invisible unlike wire braces
so you can transform
your smile without anyone noticing plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
improvement oh yeah
there's no reason there's no reason not
to have a nice
beautiful uh smile these days they got
the technology
candid only works with orthodontics
never general dentists like other
companies ooh
shots fired and with some of those other
companies you may never
hear from a doctor as you go through the
treatment
that's ridiculous with candid your
treatment includes remote monitoring by
the same orthodontist who created your
plan so you never have to wonder
how you're doing you always know i love
that
all right i don't want a garbage
collector
uh uh doing my my uh my t oh that's a
little rough on dentist
you know i don't want a garbage
collector uh rewiring my house
i don't want an electrician putting the
trash in the back of the truck i want
you know you're an orthodontist do
orthodontist
stuff right that's how it is all right
the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
them
and costs an average of 50 percent less
than
invisalign oh my god
this is like one of those old school rap
battles like is invisalign gonna have an
answer ad we shall see ready to take the
first step toward getting your dream
smile
you can't wait to show off get started
today from the comfort of your own home
with candids risk-free starter kit
and 75 dollars with and 75 off
go to candidco.com
and use the code bur that's candid
capital c
dash oh sorry about that c a n d i d
capital c dash o dot com slash bur
um code bur for your risk
free starter kit and 75 dollars off
candid
c o dot com slash bur
code bur and it's not underscore it's
the dash all right um
how much time have i done here 26 what's
up
they got to measure the windows oh for
god [ __ ] sakes can a guy do
are they here are they listening to me
screaming and yelling
they're not here so i can be here for
another four minutes right no he's here
he's just waiting in the foyer
is he listening to me screaming so i'm
gonna be in here screaming [ __ ] and all
that whether it's a guy measuring
windows
huh well i would like the last four
minutes of my podcast not me not be not
me wandering around the house trying to
figure out you know what maybe i will do
that maybe that is
something interesting to people you know
you go downstairs to your own podcast
studio
what is all that [ __ ] in my glass
jesus christ anyway no
neil let me come back up let me get up
there first all right
i don't have a mask
for [ __ ] sakes
you know a man's home is his castle
unless you're a podcaster without a
studio
then you can just go [ __ ] yourself all
right now i gotta go back all the way up
these [ __ ] stairs all right hang on
hang on live mic
live mic coming through coming to you
oh jeez all hell is breaking loose
okay everybody let's relax okay anyway
what was i talking about oh yeah you can
get your teeth straightened out
you know stop looking like you're from
britain you know you sick of being
called austin powers
you know do people start to laugh at
your joke and then you smile and then
they recoil and horror
and you look over your shoulder and look
for an axe murderer
and it turns out they're just looking at
your crooked teeth
oh my god there's no place to be in the
house i just
you know what i filled it up i filled up
the house with people
um all right here we go all right he's
back he's back
he's back in the saddle again
all right so what was that how much did
that take up oh it took up all my i got
one more minute to go and then i'm done
yay anyway so tonight
tonight i'm gonna be watching uh what
did i say the flyers
versus the friggin islanders i'm gonna
be keeping it positive
i'm gonna believe in people um
and if you want my vote in november i
want to hear some newt rockne speeches
that's what i want okay
put on one of those stupid hollywood
sports movies
um is there anything worse than i'm
going to name any movies but when they
do
the underdog guy making the team and
then they they pick the smallest [ __ ]
actor they possibly can fight it's like
this guy wouldn't make the [ __ ] team
you couldn't just cast it for a few more
weeks and found somebody with some
shoulders um
but he did the best soliloquy in the
audition
although it does work the other way
because i remember spike lee
did that move movie what did he do he
did the uh was it he got game
and i believe he used ray allen you know
he also used rick rick fox can [ __ ]
act rick fox is a good [ __ ] actor god
damn it
um what am i doing bill what are you
doing bill huh what do you have you ever
made a [ __ ] movie why don't you shut
the [ __ ] up i you know fair enough
fair enough but i've watched a lot of
them so i found
her um all right
so i am continuing on i had uh
a tofu scramble and i hate tofu
um but i actually got a good recipe for
it it's a little bit of
like one of those extra firm tofu
stand up from the 80s uh how do you know
when tofu is is cooked
it doesn't brown up or anything doesn't
seem to anyway so
i have um and i just want to give a
shout out to everybody who's going to
tell me how bad tofu is for me
um you know that also [ __ ] takes an
edible every night and then you're going
to tell me that that's good and you're
expanding your mind
and creating more distance between you
and apes
um whatever that whole [ __ ] theory is
you know um it's like an eighth
of a teaspoon of turmeric
uh and you take the whole [ __ ] brick
i kind of like tofu though when it comes
out because i feel like a drug dealer
like i got a kia cocaine
you know i have a really difficult time
not taking that gelatinous [ __ ] and just
rubbing it on my gums and reenacting
every [ __ ] cop show i watched when i
was growing up then
you mush it down with the fork and then
you stir in the tumeric
and the turmeric is i don't know it's
good for your liver or some [ __ ] i don't
know what it's good for
but what's funny is then it actually
kind of looks like scrambled eggs
then you throw like a couple [ __ ] uh
spinach in there you know and even
though you've drained off the water
there's still enough water in there you
don't put anything in the pan and you
just sort of cook it i just look at the
spinach when the spinach is all wilted
and done
then i take the [ __ ] out and meanwhile
while you're doing that you make a
little pesto sauce
which is three cups of i'm doing this by
memory here three cups of
basil leaves quarter cup
of raw cashews
then it was like uh four tablespoons of
water two
tablespoons of lemon juice two
tablespoons of olive oil
and one clove of garlic minced st put
them in a uh
what is it a uh wordpress food processor
right
there's your pesto you put it on top of
the [ __ ] that's that's gonna be your
flavor basically because you've noticed
i didn't put any salt or any of that
[ __ ]
on the [ __ ] tofu so i've been having
that
i'll finish that up tomorrow and then i
have these these
banana muffins that are made out of
buckwheat flour
that i swear to god you need like a
gallon of water to get them down your
throat they're so [ __ ] healthy right
there's nothing moist or exciting about
them
um yeah
and then i got another one this is how i
get back in shape i get this other
recipe
where you take this uh i don't know what
they call it i think it's
it's not squash yeah i think it's squash
you have them right cut the [ __ ]
thing you scoop the seeds up
all right you just rub them down with
olive oil
not in a creepy way you ask their
consent right you rub them down and then
you put some salt on them
then you put them on a cookie sheet face
down i think at like 350
for like an hour you know you just look
at them when they when the skins really
start browning up and they get soft
then you're supposed to be able to take
a fork and make these spaghetti [ __ ]
noodles out of them it never works for
me so i just scoop the [ __ ] things
out
and uh i don't know i put a little
parmesan cheese in there mix it up i
mash it down with the masher like mashed
potatoes i put a little parmesan cheese
in there
and then i just a little salt and pepper
and then i just do like layers like
lasagna and put a little ricotta cheese
between the two of them
put them back in into the broiler you
know brown it up a little bit uh oh
there's some arugula in there too
and then when i go to eat it i'll put
like a little bed of arugula and then i
put that [ __ ] on top and it [ __ ]
fills you up
and you wake up the next day and your
stomach is a little flatter
um there's a cup there's a couple of
[ __ ] uh
billy no fat tits dishes for you give
those a whirl or whatever
just what look up what i just talked
about and they'll i'm sure they'll give
you a better recipe or some [ __ ]
um so that's it oh billy fatigue billy
fat tits
billy uh pasty pasty boobs i
was thinking is there is there an
alliteration word for titties that
begins with a p
for that i guess not hey bill just a
reminder to check out that email
jesus christ it never it never ends okay
that's it
um that's the podcast have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
um if you try to be a leader out there
and just a social justice something or
other all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 27 2012.
how's it going i'm actually recording
this sunday night
because i got a bunch of [ __ ] to do
tomorrow and i got this i got this burst
of energy
on uh sunday and i was like you know
what i'm gonna
i'm gonna take care of all the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that i'm gonna hate to have to do
tomorrow morning you know i'm gonna pay
the bills
gonna go down to [ __ ] winchell's and
go get a pretzel you don't give a [ __ ]
right
is there any who the [ __ ] eats there by
the way what is winchells do they make
hot dogs
they just make that [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
food that
fat pasty white people just can't get
enough of
you know that's how you [ __ ] do it
all these all these athletes taking the
roids you don't need that you go down to
the food court orange
julius you go to that place that doesn't
like the queers
that makes the chicken sandwiches right
you get some fries from them
i love how that's part you guys have
seen that that chick-fil-a
they don't like gay people chick-fil-a
we don't like the gay
if you're straight you can eat our
[ __ ] burger if you
ain't you know then you think you're
getting enough meat in your life
buddy the [ __ ] year are we living in
more importantly how much [ __ ] money
you make in selling chicken
that you can get rid of that portion
that amount of people
in the population you know why the [ __ ]
you act like you're mcdonald's
chick-fil-a
you're not you know you're not even
popeyes
forget about kfc the [ __ ]
babe ruth michael jordan of feeding
people unhealthy chicken
you know that's your goddamn god that's
your [ __ ] led zeppelin right there
the chicken industry
right there that old [ __ ] plantation
owner
that slave that's how much that's how
[ __ ] good they are cooking chicken
they have a goddamn
who looks like a [ __ ] slave owner
straight out of that movie roots
as their their mascot or their
spokesperson you know what i mean
at least wendy's has that
non-threatening sort of [ __ ]
fat white guy you know who looks like he
loves his wife but probably you know
steals from the company if he's in the
accounting division
doesn't he he actually does look that
guy the guy from wendy's does not look
honest 100
honest he looks like a real swell guy
who
one day the the feds would show up and
uh raid his house and grab his hard
drive
and then he'd come out weeping and his
family would be all
stunned at the double life that they
weren't aware that he was leading
doesn't he look like that
can't you just see his stupid glasses
fogging up
you know and then of course he'd get
convicted right they'd go through all
the [ __ ]
nancy grace with her [ __ ] angry
hellboy head
would be sitting there you know the
[ __ ] female jim rome
right getting all [ __ ] pissed off
with flames going behind her
and then what would happen eight months
later
brian gumbel would show up or maybe he'd
send that [ __ ] vampire
uh grandpa monster there frank deford
and they would go
and interview the guy right the wendy's
guy and he'd be sitting there in his
[ __ ] jumpsuit
you know you know you know like if his
punchy hands
just ringing them together and they'd
just be like where did it all go wrong
i mean i mean you had to think at some
point
you were gonna get caught don't you i
mean
what were you thinking and then you'd
just be like
i don't know what i was thinking tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tonight on 60 minutes
that fat [ __ ] from wendy's who you
thought was an honest guy guess now he's
a piece of [ __ ]
does that make you feel better about
your life you [ __ ] [ __ ] well why
don't you go walk in the mirror and
rather than just [ __ ] brush your
teeth you look into it
and really think about some of the [ __ ]
that you've done you know and maybe
if you [ __ ] had some talent in life
you could have been a piece of [ __ ]
at that level where it'd be worthy of
telling your piece of [ __ ] stories on 60
minutes or some other
investigative news program bill where
the [ __ ] are you going with this
i'll tell you where i'm going with this
lance armstrong won that goddamn
bike race he did it seven times in a
[ __ ] row
all right and now you're telling me he
didn't
he did our [ __ ] roided up guy
beat your roided up guys seven
[ __ ] times in a row and i don't care
how you slice it
how you dice it whatever the [ __ ] you do
go [ __ ] yourself
they were all doping therefore it's an
even playing field it's like the 2004
[ __ ] boston red sox when they beat
the yankees
all right it up guys beat your roided up
guys that's level that's a level playing
field
i can't [ __ ] believe those [ __ ] they
just kept coming at him and coming at
him and then finally
everybody [ __ ] cracked you know
a bunch of goddamn [ __ ] all lining up
to [ __ ] rat the guy out
isn't is there any like
you know wasn't half the fun when you
were growing up
when the teacher knew you did something
but couldn't [ __ ] prove it and knew
that you knew
who the [ __ ] did it he just sat there
and you wouldn't [ __ ] say
[ __ ] and you got to watch this person in
power
be defeated you know what the [ __ ] are
they going to do to you
why did these other bike riding
jackasses all
crumble what were they threatening you
with i don't [ __ ] get it
let me ask you how the [ __ ] is lance
armstrong's cheating
but these old roided up guys you see at
night
night time that cinegenics they're not
cheating they're on [ __ ] hgh
they didn't earn their six-pack i'm none
of this shit's getting taken away
i it's go [ __ ] yourself all right
he won the thing he won it seven times
in a [ __ ] row i don't
i don't give a [ __ ] barry bonds
hit the most [ __ ] home runs of all
time
all right and he did it you just say he
did it during the roid era
that's all we're all gonna be on him
you know it's gonna happen no one wants
to have a chicken neck
no one wants to have your [ __ ] tits
that you never had before now
sliding into your [ __ ] stomach your
stomach's just a slit you know that's
how fat you get as you get older
when your [ __ ] navel looks like a
[ __ ] ass crack or somebody sleeping
on a couch
on its side right all the way down to
your old [ __ ] ball bag you don't want
that you want to be shredded
okay and it's already starting old
people are taking these [ __ ] things
for what because they're trying to make
division one football no
because they want to look good okay
and how do we know how to give it to
these people because they're heroes
like [ __ ] lance armstrong all the way
back to lal elzado they put this [ __ ] in
their [ __ ] bodies
and you know those [ __ ] [ __ ] out
there in silicon valley
they got to watch what happened slowly
make improvements
i'm telling you within 15 years i
guarantee you
there's going to be kids sprinkling hgh
onto their [ __ ] cornflakes
wondering why lance armstrong wasn't
allowed to say that he won that [ __ ]
bike race
seven years in a row i got [ __ ] news
for you if you want to see people
not on roids try and ride a bicycle up a
[ __ ] mountain
for six [ __ ] weeks in a row whatever
the hell it is
you want to see them do that all natural
that's gonna be the most boring [ __ ]
you've ever seen in your life you might
as well watch me do it
at that point my [ __ ] head turning
all red
wheezing just looking at the mountain
all right it's some superhero [ __ ]
okay there's no [ __ ] santa claus it's
over
all right do you think this shit's gonna
end it's not gonna end we're gonna move
on to bionic people next
they're literally gonna take out the
bottom of people's legs
below the [ __ ] kneecap and they're
gonna put a strut in there just like
they do in a car
you know and then white people are gonna
be dunking and then black people will be
like dude what the [ __ ]
you know give me some bionic legs then
you have a [ __ ]
michael jordan with bionic legs yeah i'm
telling you
by 2030 the goddamn backboard in the nba
is gonna be up where all those celtics
championship banners are
that's my theory give me a [ __ ] break
i was really rooting for that guy not
that i like cheetahs
it's you can't ride a bike 60 miles an
hour up and down a [ __ ] mountain
without being outside why is everybody
acting like this is a surprise and they
just see these
[ __ ] douchebag people in the media
right
they all they all can't [ __ ] wait to
jump all over lance armstrong's why
because they sucked in gym class
and you know you know the deal in high
school you don't get any [ __ ]
because you got an a in creative writing
all right and then these [ __ ] little
smarty kids
they see these meathead athletes walking
around with their [ __ ] abs and their
pecs going oh
[ __ ] give me the ball right and they
just sit there going why is she sucking
the dick
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and it just it bugs
them
and they can't wait they can't wait for
the day
for when one of them gets caught doing
something for them to be
fat and coming back to the reunion you
know and they can be there like oh i
[ __ ] write for this paper
huh and then they go over to that
cheerleader used to be good now
face is all [ __ ] shiny with the botox
but he still
[ __ ] grabs her by her [ __ ] hair at
this point right
you know he's got that you know that
you're not an old lady but you're not a
young lady here you know where it starts
to be extremely flammable
after all the years of highlighting it's
like a [ __ ]
goddamn bird's nest you know
sort of a dude's haircut at that point
but they added some sort of little flip
to it you know so it's still technically
a feminine haircut you're just [ __ ]
jamming it down towards your slacks
right so this is what this douche had to
say
this is what this oh by the way i forgot
to say this at the top of the podcast
uh this podcast is brought to you
today's show is brought to you by
audible please visit audible.com
bill for your free audio book download
huh why would you want to read when
someone can read it for you
why would you want to ride a bike up a
damn mountain
without having roids injected into you i
don't want to do that there's a reason
why people don't ride a bike to work
when they live on the other side of a
[ __ ] mountain all right
because it hurts your legs
you need something beyond vitamins
how [ __ ] exciting is the tour de
france
it's [ __ ] i love it i don't care
that they're on roids give them more
[ __ ] roids
make them go faster won't go fast won't
go fast they can go fast i don't give a
[ __ ]
all right so this is what this [ __ ]
douchebag wrote
he's sitting there um blah blah blah
blah he goes it's most of basically
lance tapped out all right
he said i refuse to protest if he saw
this whole like basically
ever seen that old show this is your
life
it was just like the game show where
everybody ever knew was gonna come
walking out and rather than being like
remember i taught you how to ride a
tricycle
it's not gonna be that it's gonna be a
bunch of old people going i
injected him in his buttocks and he
didn't want to deal with that
which i can't blame him um
but i gotta admit they were going after
him the way they were going after
michael jackson
you know when they said he was [ __ ]
touching kids
and i actually read an article one time
and some [ __ ] some guy wrote
he was sitting there and actually
watched the trial as opposed to me who
just kind of walked by tvs in the
airport
and looked at michael's weird nose and
were like yeah he did it
right this guy actually was at the trial
and he said he couldn't believe that it
actually went to trial
that's how [ __ ] weak the case was
you know that being said i wouldn't
leave a [ __ ] bullfrog with that
maniac
to what his [ __ ] dad did to him but
that's a whole different story it's
probably a bad point
that point actually probably just
weakened my [ __ ] argument here
anyways this is what this [ __ ] douche
who never got picked in gym class wrote
he's saying uh at this point he did okay
and all his friends are going to come
out
and basically say that he he did do it
you know can you stop yelling at me now
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um he goes at so anyways i'm sorry show
what the [ __ ]
so what was going to happen so it's the
guy writes at this point at that point
he did what he'd never done before
he gave up the pugnacious texan
continued to proclaim his
innocence but when the time came for him
to hear his friends and associates
incriminate him
and try to refute their accusations
armstrong said
said it just wasn't worth the trouble
all right
um he says i refused and armstrong said
i refuse to participate in the process
that is so one-sided and unfair
um attempting uh whatever instead
instead he's gonna focus on serving
people and families affected by cancer
attempting to be the fittest 40 year old
on the planet
i love that the fact that he did roids
somehow negates the fact that he came
back from basically you're gonna die
level cancer you had to leave one ball
on the table
you know what i mean i mean the fact
that he could even sit on a [ __ ]
bicycle seat ever again
to me is pretty [ __ ] amazing you know
i walk up my [ __ ] stairs and and
i'm winded so anyways the results means
he'll be stripped
of every medal and title he won going
back to august 1998
the exact [ __ ] thing that this nerd
writer wants
take away all his shiny stuff that i
don't know how to win
um his extraordinary career will be
vaporized from the record books
he apparently won't even be allowed to
compete in sanctioned
triathlons his recent ins uh interest
um blah blah blah blah and then he he
adds this [ __ ] here
he goes his most devoted admirers may
take his word that he was being
railroaded by a vindictive body
using unfair tactics but really what
else could a guilty person
say in the face of so much evidence
what evidence that people were going to
say he did it
i don't get how first of all is what's
what the [ __ ] i don't get
they had a hard on for this guy when he
was winning
you know you should have caught him then
when does the statute of limitations run
out on this [ __ ]
new evidence suggests what did you just
find a video of the guy [ __ ]
injecting him i don't know
anyways the agency also found that blood
tests from 2009
indicated he was doping none of this is
all [ __ ] hearsay at this point right
um his most devoted admirers may take
his word
that he was being railroaded by a
vindictive body using unfair tactics
but really what else would it go the
story is a particular shame because
armstrong who survived the 1996 bout
with statistics
testicular cancer that had spread to his
abdomen
and lungs was such an inspiration to so
many cancer victims
he used his fame to found livestrong a
foundation that provides support to
victims of the disease so what are you
telling me now
that people who have cancer are now
looking at this guy
as if he's still not like a [ __ ] hero
the guy came back from ball cancer that
had spread to his abdomen and his lungs
and won a [ __ ]
the best bike race the hardest bike race
on the planet
he won it seven years in a [ __ ] row
and banged shell shower crow
right you're telling me this guy's not
still a hero
let me ask you this person who wrote
this [ __ ] article
huh let me ask you this what about you
what have you ever [ __ ] won that
you're gonna sit here and judge a guy
like this didn't even [ __ ] go to
trial
and you're gonna sit here and talk about
this [ __ ] guy like that how what the
[ __ ] that you ever done huh
every one of your art you never cheated
on any of your articles
you never cheated on your wife you never
cheated on your taxes go [ __ ] yourself
why is this bothering me so much i don't
even [ __ ] know why it's bugging me
you know you know what it is
if everybody else in the top 20 is doing
the [ __ ] they all got caught too
all right then it's
a [ __ ] level playing field
he's so much [ __ ] better than those
other guys not only did he win the race
you still couldn't even catch him
you couldn't catch him on a bike or in
the [ __ ] lap
all those other bozos who just sitting
there staring at his ass the entire
[ __ ] race they all got caught
right whatever i'm trying
all right there you go
18 [ __ ] minutes ranting and raving
about a [ __ ] bike race all right
e-voice everybody wouldn't be great if
you could start a business in your
cubicle without your boss knowing about
it
you know well how could i do that bill
well with e-voice
um basically your mobile phone
it becomes like you can i don't know
when i read the copy i can't even
explain this thing it's so
mind-blowing to an old guy like me it's
basically you know your cell phone how
you have
you have one phone number and it rings
in order to get that phone to ring
people have to know that number would it
be great if you could have like i don't
know five
ten other numbers and that phone would
ring and no one knew your real number
wouldn't that be awesome
be a great way to start a business what
if they actually had professional voice
over actors that when you didn't pick up
the phone
it sounded like you had some sexy double
secretary and you were in this the
coolest office ever
yet it was just your cell phone huh
let me tell you this one of the great
features of e-voice
is everything i just said and it has
music on hold
dude they're creating this entire
virtual office
virtual phone numbers all of it it
doesn't even exist
man this is the greatest thing ever
makes your business seem even more
professionals e-voice will treat your
clients
and customers to music on hold you can
even set up an e-voice to run
promotional advertisements for your
company
while people are on hold instead of
music all of this
lending to your credibility as this
wheeler and dealer sitting there smoking
a stogie e-voice also has the call
recording feature which is perfect for
any doctor lawyer
real estate agents hiring managers or
any other professional
uh discussing contracts easy to use
as you just press star 2 to start and
start 2 to stop
that's it perfect if you're driving and
can't write something important down
e-voice makes your life easier and seem
more professional
for your free six-month trial go to w
www.evoice.com
slash bill burr www.evoice.com
billboard or go to the banner ad on my
podcast page at billboard.com we
actually
had a listener raving about it
starting his own business on on twitter
sent me a great
uh a great tweet about it i should i
should really retweet that but the
people at evoice
were doing backflips they were so
excited that uh somebody actually used
it and
and had the results that they claimed so
there you go
if you're trying to start your own
business all right
back to the podcast what else happened
oh the red sox
the red sox had a fire sale
i love it i gotta tell you this i
absolutely love it
okay and i'm just equating the red sox
basically to van halen
this is basically what happened we had
david lee roth everything was great
2004 maybe 2007 after we won the second
one
that's like 2004 to 2007. that was like
van halen
won all the way to 1984.
all right and then what happened tito
left
david lee left and now we got sammy
hagar
now we just dumped all the players so
that's to me is like sammy hagar and
michael anthony aren't in the band
anymore
and now we got gary sharon no gary
sharon's in
i don't know what to tell you all i can
tell you this is what i love about this
what i love about my own team just [ __ ]
in the bed
the way that they do is i love the empty
seats
i love it i love seeing all the
bandwagon go home
like the bandwagon [ __ ] that i knew
you were
you weren't there when we sucked you
showed up when we started getting good
and you wrote it out
like all those [ __ ] [ __ ] who fill up
the stadium now
every time the patriots play a game
where the [ __ ] were you back when we had
that shitty stadium with the aluminum
seats
where were you huh you were nowhere you
were sitting at home
drinking hot cocoa with your [ __ ]
slippers on you know and i know a lot of
people right now are probably going to
be going yeah cause [ __ ] boston [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck
[ __ ] you all right look at your own
goddamn stadium you want to see what
your fan base says if you really want to
see the true fan base of your team
go to a game when they suck on any level
hockey basketball baseball football
rugby
[ __ ] tiddlywinks whatever it is when
your team
sucks and the people that go those are
the die hards
i can't believe there's already empty
seats at fenway park up to everything
that that team's done for that city
okay we're only 11 months in they've had
an 11 month bad run i was back there in
boston all these [ __ ] people crying
pissing and moaning
a bunch of [ __ ] babies you know what
the greatest thing about the bandwagon
people leaving
is i i think it ups the chance of that
stupid song
to be discontinued during the seventh
inning stretch is there any way we can
sell that song to the dodgers too is
there any way
we could just get rid of that sweet care
will lie
[Music]
you know if i was a dictator and i was
looking to trim down the population
i wouldn't play that song in in the
public square with the banner of my face
you know all around it
and i would play that whoever sang along
that would be it you the black van would
show up to your [ __ ]
house and you would be you would be uh
you would be
automatically signed up for my
re-educational program
which basically involves your skull
being used as a [ __ ]
lamp post um i'm sorry that doesn't even
make a lampshade maybe i don't know what
the [ __ ] that's
what am i trying to say a footstool
there you go
um so i'm actually excited i think it's
a great [ __ ] thing
i think it's great for the red sox
yankees rivalry
you know red sox suck so much that they
now now they don't have to [ __ ] amp
it up that they
they're going to face each other and
then that can just you know
back off for a little bit and then maybe
in a couple years it gets good again you
know it's supposed to be like
they're meeting again 27
times this year 200 million versus 180
who gives a [ __ ]
it's over so i want to thank the red sox
for [ __ ] back to like all the way
from 1999 on i haven't had a [ __ ]
problem with you guys it's been [ __ ]
an absolute joy
to watch you play all right it's been
[ __ ] great and now you're going
through the rough times
and you know i'm still going to watch i
can't [ __ ] wait to watch
whatever the [ __ ] is left of this team
play in september
you know i don't know why
can you can you people in boston do me a
favor can you guys can
can we start a movement to start booing
that [ __ ] song during the seventh
inning stretch
can somebody start a website could
somebody
okay i'm lighting the match somebody go
get the gas
let's just let's just go for a
a total clean slate here all right
to start and over again for some reason
bobby they're sticking with bobby v
i don't know why and for some reason the
more he goes out and yells at umpires
i'm actually starting to like the guy um
all right so he's on hold but can we can
we just
get rid of that [ __ ] song
you know one of the great things i used
to tease yankee fans about was the fact
that they sang
ymca during the seventh inning stretch
okay
i i never understood why they did it the
the legendary
franchise that it is i just you're
singing this village people song
and everybody in the stands is going
whoa mca
douchebags are douchebags are not real
yankee fans they're not doing it they're
[ __ ] sitting there you know
i don't know what they're doing pulling
their hat down over their eyes it's
[ __ ] embarrassing
it's embarrassing okay but that's not my
[ __ ] problem
can we please as a red sox fan
who started watching back when they
actually had red hats
that clown hat that they wore in the 70s
first game we went to was in
in 78 the summer 78 by the way um
what was it 78 yeah 78
yeah can we please let's start with the
song
let's get rid of the song this will be
like a fan
fire sale we'll start with the song and
then next will be that
[ __ ] mascot okay
and uh i don't know where to go from
there because i don't live there anymore
those two [ __ ] things annoy the [ __ ]
out of me
get that struggling actor out of that
[ __ ] suit
okay i hate mascots
i've said this before i hate when you
talk to him when there's no kids around
and they still won't say anything
and you're like hey what's going on and
they do that [ __ ] you know
i smoke crystal meth [ __ ] psycho nod
at you
you know it's insulting
i know you're in there
um anyways this is such a weird [ __ ]
podcast so far
um i'm just gonna go off on [ __ ] this
week and then i'm just gonna read
advertising huh
does that work for you guys legalzoom
everybody legalzoom
would you like to get incorporated would
you like to uh write out a will
would you like to to copyright something
that you invented
and you don't want some big corporation
to steal it from you
you don't want your eggs to start having
the aftertaste of almonds
would you like to avoid that all right
legalzoom.com uh you've probably heard
about legalzoom if you're on youtube
they have all kinds of ads on there but
now i
am telling you about them so you got to
check these guys out because uh they're
great
all right if you've been waiting for the
perfect time to start your own business
it's right now it's time to get out of
the cubicle okay
incorporate your business or form an llc
legalzoom.com starting at just 99
bucks i paid 1500 i went the sap route
you can do it yourself for 99 bucks and
if you have a family guess what you need
to make sure that they're protected
you can protect your family and assets
with the legal zoom will
for just 69 bucks 99 bucks you're
incorporated
69 bucks everyone you love is taken care
of
is protected you know you're still under
200 bucks
all right go down to aldos get yourself
a pair of loafers
in the past 12 years do they ever feel
good those aldo shoes
how long how many days do you have to go
getting the blisters before you ever
broke those in
in the past 12 years over 2 million
americans have used legal zoom for llc's
wills trusts
trademarks and more they save hundreds
even thousands of dollars versus going
the traditional lawyer rook uh lawyer
root um
legal zooms online process guides you
step by step
and you get a total customer support it
couldn't be much easier they even have
an attorney to help you if you need to
get through any of their legal stuff
um start your business and protect your
family today at legalzoom.com
you also get a special discount from
listening to this podcast
make sure you enter bur b-u-r-r in the
referral box at the checkout
for more savings legalzoom is not a law
firm and self-help services are provided
at your discretion your direction sorry
all right so if you get confused don't
just sit there and wait for a lawyer to
help you out you call them up
and they're going to help you okay there
you go back to the podcast
all right so
see my dog my dog is so adorable
just laying there sleeping you wanna
hear how she sounds when she's sleeping
you know what i'm not gonna because i'm
putting the microphone up to her nose
and all it's gonna do is gonna wake her
up and you guys are not gonna see how
adorable she is because this is not a
visual medium in case you haven't
noticed
so i'm really going to do is just wake
her up um
anyways i've been off this whole week
i'm off next week and then it's [ __ ]
on
i'm torn like a goddamn band speaking of
which i saw truth and salvage company at
the troubadour
on uh friday night and uh if you get a
chance to see those guys live
if you're sick of auto-tune and a bunch
of people acting like they're singing
but they're not singing
because they got to do a bunch of dance
steps if you would just like to see
a band of talented musicians everybody
in the band can sing their asses off
it's it's everything that's great about
music
um first of all i never been to the
troubadour and i always heard about that
obviously being a guns n roses fan so
before i went over there
uh look it up on um on
on wikipedia i will try to give you a
link or something like that for it
um but just the amount of people that
started out there
you know it just it just was
mind-blowing all those singer-songwriter
people that were out in l.a and lived in
laurel canyon
the joni mitchells the james taylors all
the way through
right through to who else did they have
there
i can't remember it was just a who's who
of everybody
and then guns and roses of course
performed there back when axel had like
two tattoos they got all the pictures on
the wall so i'm psyched to go there i
thought it was gonna be this huge place
it only held like
maybe 350 people really intimate setting
and i went down there and they
absolutely smashed it
and uh they're actually out here
recording a new album truth and salvage
company check them out
if you like real music all right and
that wasn't a paid advertisement that
came from the [ __ ] high
all right here we go so anyways i am on
the road traveling like a band
all right not this [ __ ] comedy [ __ ]
where it's one week and then i sit at
home staring at my toes and then maybe
i'll do another two days
this is hardcore i am traveling i
believe
for the next [ __ ] six weeks maybe
every weekend i'm working all right
um here we go orlando improv september
7th
8th and ninth you know i was gonna try
to go to a gators game
florida gators right drive up and go to
game course they're [ __ ] not playing
sons of [ __ ] um is there anything
else near there the seminoles where
the [ __ ] do they play i gotta see some
florida college football when i'm there
i'm in orlando if you can recommend
something let me know
bill billberg.com um all right comedy
zone
charlotte north carolina september 13th
14th and 15th
and then my triumphant return i love
saying that
i just coming back to new york but i
call it my triumphant return
as if i went off and conquered something
um actually this is the rescheduled date
the caroline's date september 20th 21st
22nd and 23rd i will be working with
the one and only teen idol sensation
from the opium anthony radio
program joey rose's joe derosa
will be there loaning his headlining
services
okay to to be a feature act
something he doesn't do he's just doing
it for a pal
something he's way beyond this guy sold
millions of records everybody
millions of joey roses fans cannot be
wrong he's going to be in the feature
act
and uh opening is uh one of my new
favorite comics out there is this kid
sean patton he's [ __ ] awesome
so that's going to be a great show all
right and then the week after that i'm
going to be at the comedy zone
in jacksonville florida okay how about a
little pause here and a round of
applause for the amount of white trash
people i am going to be serving
and dancing for in
[ __ ] september orlando florida
who goes there unless you're going to
disney world nobody
maybe if you're a [ __ ] and you want to
blow tiger woods i don't know
right comedy zone charlotte north
carolina
and then after that i'm in [ __ ] two
weeks later i'm in jacksonville florida
okay am i [ __ ]
am i doing stand-up or am i oh my god a
reoccurring role
on east bounded down okay you tell me
this should be a jet ski at the end of
this [ __ ] tour that's all i'm saying
after that i go to go bananas in
cincinnati ohio
all right you want that cincinnati is
one of those cities that even people in
cincinnati don't go to
they leave it's one of those cities
right at five o'clock everybody leaves
zombie [ __ ] town just like cleveland
just like buffalo
just like all of those [ __ ] rust belt
goddamn towns
people just leave and i'm sitting there
walking down the street it's scary
but i'm gonna be there at go bananas
then after that i go to [ __ ] sydney
australia
hopefully i go to sydney australia
[ __ ] breaking my balls with all this
[ __ ] they want me to give them
so um i actually set this tour up
because i thought my special was going
to be coming out october 1st but the
people at netflix were so damn excited
they're such great people they're like
bill why don't we put it out now what
are we waiting for i said okay
right so now i got all these [ __ ]
back-to-back dates to put together my
new hour
um so please come down say hello
laugh at a couple of jokes two for one
joey roses
telling you one of you in what in his
final engagement is a feature act
um all right what else do we got here
did i tell you guys i'm trying to learn
how to make homemade pizza
how bad do i need to just have a [ __ ]
kid already how many more hobbies can i
start
oh look who's up it's cleo
come here buddy come here come over here
come over here you know all [ __ ] day
long you've been coming over here
being all needy and the one time i call
you when the goddamn microphone's on you
won't come over
right once i know i always use this
reference but it's like that goddamn
frog
right remember was singing for that
construction worker and that cartoon
hello my baby hello my honey right
then you go to show it to people and
just go bur
uh yeah i'm trying to learn how to make
pizza if anybody has a good recipe for a
sauce because that's where it's all
about that in the [ __ ] crust
all right i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about anymore let's plow ahead
here uh
what do i have what else have i written
down here that i want to talk about
bombing oh jesus i ate my balls
at the comedy store saturday night
just for like the first like minute and
a half because you know what i was doing
i was opening
with the bit that's on my new special
that i opened with the fact i was
talking about wanting to get a gun
so i just kind of you know had always
been opening with that and now that my
special's out there
i'm so delusional i just automatically
assume that everyone who's ever going to
go to a comedy club
my dog needs a bath
here at itching cleo enough come here
get over here
so anyways i've been um
sorry i gotta give her the old neck
scratch here
there you go there you go you
[ __ ]
get out of here um
yeah so i've been opening with that so i
was like well it's been on once it's on
tv i can't i gotta i gotta
dump the joke so i had this weird thing
when i was going out there and i knew
everything that i was gonna talk about i
just didn't know i was gonna open with
so i was like yeah
just [ __ ] i don't know and i wasn't
feeling funny
and it was uh it was a long
two three minutes before i kind of got
it going and then i was like
it just wasn't clicking for me um
and you know something that really
wasn't even a part of like building a
new hour it just had to do with the fact
that i haven't been on stage for a
minute and it's just like going to the
gym
i was getting winded in my cleo are you
gonna [ __ ] scratch for the rest of
the podcast
you need a bath you know that
you need a bath go back to sleep you
were doing great
this [ __ ] dog i swear to god this
thing it sleeps
like 20 hours a day you know all the
[ __ ] that they say about pit bulls being
vicious and that type of thing i don't
know when they do it
all you really have to do if you get a
dog is just watch it for that critical
four hours when it's awake and you're
gonna
you're fine um all right let's
let's get to a goddamn question here
advice exotic pets uh bill last week i
was laid off from my office cubicle job
of four years
i am now a 25 year old unemployed
college student
struggling to make rent ah jesus my
heart goes out to you brother but at
least you're 25 you're not [ __ ]
married you don't have any kids that's
the bright side and i know you don't
need to hear that
all right all right here we go can't go
back to my parents as they are halfway
across the planet in taiwan
now my question is do i continue to do i
continue trying to get back
in the rat race or do i follow my dream
of becoming an exotic
pet reptile breeder
jesus christ how the [ __ ] do i are you
just [ __ ] with me
this is your dream well you know what
you are from taiwan i imagine everything
that's considered exotic over here is
like nothing
you know i bet over in taiwan instead of
getting like a bicycle
as a four-year-old they give you like a
defanged cobra or some [ __ ]
um
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i just had to stop and laugh
at the ignorance of that statement
um anyways i have no experience in the
field
fantastic you're gonna be on spike tvs a
thousand ways to die
except okay except that okay i have no
experience in the field except for
that i have a snake and four hamsters
as pets all right dude i don't want to
burst your bubble but there's nothing
exotic
about hamsters even if you have four
or quattro sorry i started the new
[ __ ] rosetta stone spanish again
yo tango um it's greece a blanco
pero es bueno is loco hey loco how the
[ __ ] you say it my dog's out of its mind
[Music]
like i just said the woman and then
green apple
there's really nothing that connected
either one of those now go [ __ ] yourself
i'm gonna do it at some point my life
i'm gonna become bilingual
so anyways this dude wants to start
raising exotic pets
breeding them he has no experience now
what kind of [ __ ] snake do you have
you know if you have a garden gardener i
guess you got to start somewhere
you do have a reptile and uh four little
rat things
this is cool dude you know what you're
doing you're doing like the open mics of
this i get it
you gotta start slow you can't start
right with the black mamba
you're gonna get yourself killed anyways
he said i've been to the reptile expo a
couple of times and saw that vendors
there just breed and sell
snakes for a living and thought to
myself holy [ __ ] i want to do that
encourage animals to bang and sell the
offspring
all from my own apartment living the
dream
what to do any advice uh what gave you
the balls to start stand up
um understanding the opportunity cost of
the income of a full-time job
uh any advice would help thanks mr burr
all right
all right what do you do here well dude
you're doing the right thing
you basically like you you going to one
of those uh reptile expos and looking at
the douche bags doing it
and being like i could [ __ ] do that
was like me when i used to watch
some of those stand-up shows and be like
i'm funnier than this guy
all right and you have the luxury of not
having a job right now
so you don't have to worry about you
know well what if this interferes with
my job you don't have a [ __ ] job
um your biggest thing right now dude is
you need income
all right so i would continue looking
for a job
that is flexible all right while you
start building your stockpile of uh
reptiles first thing i would do is i
would go on the internet and i would
read as much as humanly possible
i would go to howtomake2snakesfuck.com
i would start i don't know what to tell
you dude
i would just keep going to those expos
like their open mics i would keep
reading up on it i would try and find
uh this is what you do this is what you
do
act like you want to buy a [ __ ] snake
and go to some [ __ ] dude and ask them
how they got into the business as you
pretend like you know
like you're browsing maybe you can get a
job working for one of those guys you
figure out what the [ __ ] he's doing
right you pull the joe kennedy that i've
learned
reading in the wonderful book the sins
of the father
um yeah that guy used to work every
place he'd work at a place for like
seven months to two years he'd rifle
through all the files
get all this insider information make a
boatload of cash
and leave the [ __ ] company in the
[ __ ]
okay now i'm not saying to do that but
[ __ ] work for these other guys figure
out what they're doing
do what they're doing become better at
it that's what i would do if you really
want to do this [ __ ] i would
but uh i gotta tell you this man um
i don't know how you make two pit vipers
[ __ ] each other
but uh i would definitely get a uh
i don't know i get a thick pair of
gloves
how do reptiles even get turned on they
just have that [ __ ] look on their
face
like you don't know what they're
thinking you know
i'll tell you if snakes had [ __ ]
hands like they would win world series
of poker every year there'd be no
[ __ ] way to tell what it had
said holding [ __ ] has they got a full
house i can't [ __ ] just
sit there sticking his tongue at me
should i go bill i need your help
obviously i must have some real issues
to be seeking advice from a stand-up
comedian but here goes you know what
dude that's one of the truest things
that's ever been said
um anyways you know some i was talking
to bobby lee
this weekend who i'm gonna have on the
podcast i love the guy to death
and he said a couple really nice things
to me and when we were backstage
and as i went to return the compliments
he literally imploded and ran out of the
room
just at the the thought of hearing me
say something nice about him
and i just laughed because he was making
a joke about it but he was seriously he
seriously left
and slammed the door as i was mid
complimenting him and left me in this
room by myself
and i just laughed out loud to myself
and just said [ __ ] comedians
so sir you're 100 right to sit there and
be to seek advice from a stand-up
comedian you got to be out of your mind
but
this advice is free here we go a couple
years ago i decided to travel the world
he says due to borden or she says who
the [ __ ] knows
uh due to borden and just a general
feeling of unhappiness
that's a good thing to do i needed to
get away
everything went great from there i met
so many good people enjoyed my time in
other countries and ended up feeling so
much better in the end
uh yeah dude you had an adventure i
said i recently decided to go home for a
visit before continuing on
and it ended up in a disaster
oh so you were still traveling the world
you decided to go home or you were back
in the states and decided to go to your
hometown
i don't know either way you went home
from wherever the hell you were at
my parents were fighting most of my
friends had either changed or
left and it turned out to be a real
shitty time for me
the question is am i wrong to want to
travel still
i am leaving again straight away and
most people i know are making me feel
terrible that i want to leave
it's nothing personal i just don't feel
happy here and i really miss the friends
that i made in other places
should i make the people feel bad or is
it time
to tell them to suck a big fat one
oh should i let people make me feel bad
or is it time
to tell them to suck the big fat one uh
dude you're following your heart it's a
great story
you should go for it and you learned the
awful lesson that everybody has to learn
is that you can never go home
okay because people move on people
change you walk into that bar
and you're not going to see anybody that
you know anymore and if you do they're
going to be a lot
fatter and a lot sadder something awful
is going to happen
you know they ruptured this spleen you
just don't want to do it
you just don't want to do it you know
so go live your life the reason why you
feel happy when you're out there
traveling i feel is because you're
following your heart
you're listening to that voice that's
telling you what to do you go back to
that town everybody's negative people
are fighting
of course they don't want you to leave
they don't want you to make something
yourself because they're still sitting
there
sipping on a [ __ ] miller so yeah you
don't have to tell them to suck a big
fat one you just be like you know this
is what i want to do
and then just send him cards from all
over the world and that'll make him even
more angry as they sit there watching
you get blown in venice
on one of those [ __ ] boats with that
dude in the striped shirt
he's not blowing you of course some
other chick with a mole right above her
lip
and he's sitting there singing a song
trying to drown out the sound of her
sucking your dick that's basically how
it goes down is that a good picture
you know
hey you know what why don't you [ __ ]
go travel go buy some exotic snakes and
sell them to that other dude who's
trying to sell is to start his business
then you take the money that you made
right
and you [ __ ] use that to travel more
see that
connecting via the podcast all right we
got a fat [ __ ] redemption we got a
redemption here
this is a nice shout out to uh tosh.0
this guy's obviously a tosh.0 fan i'm
not trying to steal anything from that
show
fat [ __ ] redemption bill i'm a 35 year
old guy and i've been a big fat [ __ ] for
most of my life well
you know what sir the first step is
admitting it
the fact that you can call yourself a
big fat [ __ ]
you know it's like me when i go through
my periods when i know i need to quit
drinking
it's what i say to myself oh billy fat
again big
[ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] head full of booze big john
travolta [ __ ] head loser
stop your drinking that's what i do or
else i won't listen to myself
has this podcast going off the rails i
feel like i can't even think right now
um anyways i developed an amazing set of
breasts
at the tender age of 13.
all right this is a guy i just had a
look at the name uh that still puts both
of my sister's racks to shame
420 pounds was my heaviest but i am also
six foot seven and built white and built
like the iris sasquatch
so i carry it pretty well you see what
i'm saying this is why this guy's so
funny
he grew tits at 13. he's six foot seven
he's 420 pounds there's no way to not
look like that and not be a funny
[ __ ]
um about 10 years ago i dropped 150
pounds through it through diet and
exercise
i had a whole new life new career
beautiful women the whole shebang
i had to get a good seven year run
yeah dude that's great man seven years
you're a funny [ __ ] you're six
foot seven
they probably feel like they're being
held by a big bear
you make them feel safe the next thing
you know they're [ __ ] you i totally
see it
totally see it so anyways he says so
here's my dilemma
about three years ago i got off the
track
and put a lot of the weight back on and
haven't had a girlfriend the whole time
mostly by choice ah you went to some
self-loathing thing
i'm back in the groove now dropping the
weight and getting healthy again
i want to settle down and start
something serious with the woman of my
dreams but i still have about 50
60 pounds to work off in a perfect world
it would be all about
inner beauty and personality and [ __ ]
but let's be realistic
a smart talented good-looking
health-conscious woman
is just not going to settle for a dude
who is swinging around bigger tits than
her
you know what dude personality goes a
long way but
you're 100 right when you're talking
about the man tits you got to get rid of
them
he says i suck at casual dating and i
tend to get sucked into long-term
relationships very easily
so my question is do i wait till i'm in
the prime
shape again before i start getting
serious with anyone
i'm not trying to be perfect but i'm not
looking for perfection but i just want
to be smart about it
what do you think about the bricktop um
all right you have to learn how to
not only are you losing weight but you
got to learn how to date dude
all right you've addressed that you're a
fat [ __ ] and you're dealing with that
you also got to address that you're uh
you're codependent
and you're [ __ ] lonely all right
and it sucks if you co-depend you're a
relationship guy
so it's very easy for you to get sucked
into relationships but
you know you can't take the first thing
that comes down the pike
so what you you this is the deal you so
know that you get sucked into
relationship that's what i think
that you're like all right so if i'm
gonna get sucked into a relationship i
have to look
the best that i can possibly look so
when i do get sucked into a relationship
i got a [ __ ] you know top shelf girl
that i'm doing it with
um i don't know i don't think that
that's gonna work
personally i think you need to learn how
to date just go out and start dating
and and why don't you say that i would
say that
on the date so where is this going um
just be like you know what i'm in a
period of my life when i'm trying to
learn how to date
what is what does that mean it means
that i'm one of those i'm a relationship
guy and i tend to get sucked into
relationships
and uh next thing you know i'm in a
relationship with someone i should have
just had one or two dates with
so you know i'm not trying to be
uh i'm just being upfront that's where
i'm at right now
so uh i have a list of questions and
judging by your answers
uh will depend what there's gonna be
date number two
you don't have to say that last part but
uh definitely you gotta you gotta you
gotta come at it that way man
just come right out of the gate like
that you know something
you'll get some [ __ ] ass even with
your goddamn tits
talking like that you walk into a bar
right you sit there you already got a
sense of humor you make them [ __ ]
laugh
some girls eventually going to come
walking up to you some mess
or maybe some [ __ ] borderline cutie
they're insecure too you know
maybe they don't like their [ __ ] ass
who knows what right they come walking
up to you
what's your deal what are you doing just
sitting here
you know and you just start talking
about there's nothing a [ __ ] broad
likes better
than some [ __ ] guy who's sitting
there who's actually taking stalking
himself
who seems like he's going to start
taking life seriously okay
because they look at us and they see us
for the morons that we are
led by our dicks playing in mud puddles
breaking [ __ ] acting like a bunch of
[ __ ] gorillas
so when they see somebody who's actually
sitting there contemplating about where
the [ __ ] they're going in life and what
they want
they're attracted to it not to mention
you're six foot seven they're gonna feel
safe and then they gotta be wondering
well is this dick five foot seven right
so you just hit him with that line what
are you doing i'm trying to figure life
up i have to learn how to date and
they'll be all over it
what do you mean dating's easy you
should have fun
next thing you know her [ __ ] hands on
your thigh right
a couple of limes in the coronas and
extina whatever all right
hey that's what that's what i hope
happens for you all right
the last one here before i wrap up the
podcast do i have any other [ __ ]
average let me let's let's
[ __ ] try to i know you guys don't
like listening all these [ __ ] ads but
i got to do them here all right
amazon.com would you like to [ __ ]
support this podcast
and the wounded warriors project well
this is all you got to do go to
billboard.com
click on the podcast page and then click
on the banner ad the amazon
banner ad will take you right to amazon
you don't have to do anything like that
go on there
go buy yourself a drum stool or a
[ __ ] ladle whatever you want to do
amazon kicks me a percentage of whatever
you spent and then i take 10
basically of all the advertising that i
have on this and i kick it over to the
wounded warriors project
so you'd be help supporting this project
and the troops
all right can you get any better than
that i don't think you can but i'll tell
you what's a close second
gamefly.com oh what a segway what a
professional
um basically go to the banner ad once
again
on billboard.com on the podcast page and
you click on the banner
for your free two-disc two-week free
trial
23 value over 40 people did that last
month so thank you very much for that
and hopefully you will enjoy the service
if you want a free two-week trial go to
www.gamefly.com
or their banner on my podcast page for
your free trial and enjoy
all the video games you can play 8 000
video games a free two-week trial you're
out of your mind
go buy a big bag of doritos and a 12
pack of your favorite soda
because you got 8 000 games to play
mister or ma'am
is there anything hotter than a [ __ ]
chick that likes to play video games
you know like like those violent ones i
don't even know what they're called
anymore i had to wean myself off of
halo and that type of stuff
i don't know i think it's cool all right
the last one here i don't even know if
this one's true guys
um i hope this is true
i don't know but this this this seems
too true
to i mean too unbelievable to be true
this is called threesome
says dear bill i was a virgin who never
wrote in but listen to your
listen to you respond to other virgins
who wrote in i am 19
not exactly old but who wants to break
20 before blowing your load and a
teenage girl
the remarkable part um is that i had a
threesome to kick off my new life
as not a virgin see that
this guy's trying to make me believe
that right out of the gate i mean it can
happen
people get called up from the miners
their first [ __ ] time you know they
hit for the [ __ ] cycle
they throw a perfect game it can happen
but i'm reading this one with a grain of
salt i don't know if this is a listener
[ __ ] with me or what but here we go
he said i met this girl let's see how
believable this sounds
all right then we'll take a vote whether
you believe this or not i hope it's true
anyways i met this girl at the beach
last summer and ran into her again
sometime in july
she was being very flirty and kept
talking about her summer bucket list
she said her and her friend had the same
goal
i thought they meant that they
separately wanted to get deflowered
not thinking that hey everyone is
probably
probably getting laid
i figured we were all on the same page
oh so you thought that they were both
virgins so a week back
i invited to a party my friend was
having
she brings her friend and her friend is
hotter
i start working on her because i'm drunk
and on a roll
and i'm going for broke good for you
good for you
in fact at one point another dude came
in to interrupt the conversation
and i gave him a whoa you gotta
you gotta raise your hand what does that
mean
he raised oh all right you gotta raise
your hand to come into the conversation
jesus christ this kid took his fonzy
pills uh he said he uh he raised his
hand
and i called him a clown everyone
laughed
what a [ __ ] idiot he did that anyways
why wouldn't i think this girl want
wanted to bang wait a minute dude how
are you this [ __ ] cool you never got
any ass before this doesn't make any
sense
you're coming off like uh billy ray
valentine here anyways well it turns out
her and her friends wanted to have a
threesome
i realized this when they both told me
flat out that they wanted to
i went for it bill i didn't really know
what i was doing for the first 10
seconds or so but after that it just all
made sense like when neil saw the matrix
i couldn't have done it without the
podcast now let me ask you this do you
guys believe that
i didn't know what i was doing for the
first 10 seconds and then you all of a
sudden you understood
but then he makes a reference to neil in
the matrix which is something that a
[ __ ] nerd would do
i don't know it's a hell of a story i
hope it's true
it just it just doesn't make sense
you're a [ __ ] virgin you get a
threesome the first time
without paying for it you know
you [ __ ] you have the ball you're a
[ __ ] virgin but you have the
[ __ ] you're making the move of a guy
who's gotten laid where you go for the
even harder one
and then you stop the guy from [ __ ]
blocking you
you know i mean unless you're in
absolute you're the
[ __ ] the natural there's no way how
do you have all these skills that you
never got laid before i'm calling
[ __ ] on this one i hope it's true
i hope it's true i really do and if it
is true i want to know what the [ __ ] you
were drinking
um all right is that the podcast i don't
know if it is wait wait wait wait wait
stamps.com i forgot stamps.com everybody
snaps.com
if you would like to stop going to the
post office wouldn't it be great if you
could stop going there yet be able to do
everything that you could do
at the post office within your own place
of where you live
print stamps have your own scale
weigh packages be able to run off little
metered uh
whatever the hell the box costs sorry i
don't have the copy i think i have it
memorized at this point
go to stamps.com type in bur
for your free two-week trial of
stamps.com
you know the deal you guys listen to
this stuff every week you don't have to
go to the post office anymore you just
go to stamps.com you get you can print
out
legal postage you get your own scale
it's wonderful i send out all my dvds
that whole month of touring that i have
i'm not going to the post office month
i'm going to once i'm going to send out
all of my dvds using stamps.com
all right so there you go that is the
podcast for this week thank you guys so
much for listening
thank you guys for uh going to amazon
helping me uh
you know and actually you know helping
out the wounded warriors project it's uh
it's one of the few like wholesome
things that i do in my life
so that's it is that how we're going to
go out do i not have anything else to
talk about i'm gonna end on a damn
commercial well i did say thank you
i am over the hour i've done my goddamn
time here
oh my battery's down to one little cell
there all right so it's gonna wipe out
anyways all right
so that's it please come out and see me
in orlando florida
charlotte north carolina new york city
jacksonville florida
cincinnati sydney australia
i'm going to be on the night of too many
stars
in new york city and uh
what else do i don't know what else i
got coming up that's gonna be me the
next six weeks espana dan loaded up and
trucking
i'm going to all the white trash [ __ ]
cities so bring your tattoo
titties and your stupid [ __ ]
boyfriend pull up in your truck with the
steel nuts hanging off the back
go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week
you